[Music]
we were talking with jerry going into
the break he's beginning to tell us his
story so you get to start over jerry
tell us what's up yes sir so um as i
said i
had 29 000 in debt and i paid 4 000
within the first few months watching you
through youtube
and i have 25 000.
uh 2500 is credit card and 10 000 is a
personal loan that i actually took
from this cover uh which i have 21
interest
charge on it um and that i took it
because of
um i was going to get married and i
actually married in india
and uh i took a fifteen thousand dollars
from my parents uh
for ask them for a loan also
um my wife lives in india right now and
her paperwork are getting ready
um getting for her to come to united
states and she's never been on a train
and i wanted to be there to help her out
with the procedures and stuff
and it will take me about six thousand
dollars to
um go to india and do everything that
needs to be done
so all my debts i've been paying um 200
300
extra to try to get everything paid off
so i can i made an arrangement with my
parents where once i take care of my
debt i'll pay them
pay theirs uh completely also
um i just uh another question that i
have is also for sure
so what is your question okay so
i'm paying a little extra for my um
to my debt so should i actually stop
or pay and bare minimum and start saving
for
uh going to india yeah you should stop
everything take six jobs and go get your
wife
yeah yes sir i have a question jerry
jerry you said it
you want to be there she's never been on
a plane before so you want to go to
india
and be there to help her through the
whole process and that's gonna cost six
grand i just think it's worth asking
what would it cost if you didn't go
there and you just had somebody on the
ground there in india that you trust
that helps her get on the plane how much
money would you save if
you were just here when she got here it
would be thirty five hundred dollars
i'd go that option what do you make a
year
forty thousand sir yeah yeah so
the difference is a lot of money i just
started a a job
where um i got it promoted to this job
um when they when they asked for how
much i was uh
they want me to um they want to give me
uh sort of salary goes i took the bare
minimum also
but i actually helped with the current
job that i have i have probably
two other departments uh um to run their
projects and stuff like that can
so um is it a good time for me to ask
stories because i've been there a year
and a half and
they they love me and they give me
already three four bonuses
rather than a race so is it a good time
for me to ask them to race because i was
concerned because of colgate and
you know things like that jerry jerry
jerry jerry
i don't think you should ask for a raise
i i i
tell people don't ask for a raise here's
what happens when you go in and you ask
for raise
whether you do it really nicely very
professionally or not it
it inevitably puts your leader in a
defensive posture
even if they're healthy and a good
leader what you need to do
we have two separate questions here so i
want to address the raised thing in just
a second but never ask
just don't go in and ask for raise
because you've been there for a year and
a half and all these good things
first thing is let's go back to what
dave said uh you've been paying an extra
300
a month towards your debt take that
money plus two other jobs your wife's
not here
so you got lots of time on your hands
two or three jobs to come up with 3 500
that's my recommendation don't spend six
when you can spend 35 there's somebody
in india who can get your wife on the
plane
and get her here safely you're there
when she gets off the plane
and a lot faster so 3 500 bucks is your
goal
how many jobs how quickly can you get
the 3 500 bucks that's your singular
goal
now the second issue on the raise here's
what i teach on the ken coleman show
you don't ask for raise you ask for a
growth plan now ramsay solutions we have
a wonderful process
by which every person on their
anniversary of their start date they
have an annual review
and we also have a one sheet that we
call
uh uh what is it uh uh geez i just
blanked out
uh key results are kra sorry i've i got
my letters jumbled
kra and it says this is what a win looks
like for ken coleman this is what i'm
responsible for
a win for ken coleman would be able to
remember them you actually remember
yes to actually remember the kra i was
so excited and so quick i got so fired
up so here's the deal
here's what i want you to do i want you
to sit down with your leader and say hey
if you do not have a kra and if you do
not have an annual review i want you to
go to your leader and ask for those
things
hey can we sit down and work together
you give your leaders some skin in the
game
and you're not asking for a raise you're
saying hey i want to grow
i want to grow in my abilities here i
want to grow the value
and responsibilities that i can bring to
this company what
can i do that makes me worth more money
and then say
how do we measure those results on that
growth which will then lead to
greater responsibility greater influence
and greater income when you package it
that way it's not
what do i need to do to get a raise or
can we talk about arrays the raise
comes with the increase the measurement
that's what i think you should do yeah
if you just switch shoes for a second
with your employer it tells you exactly
how to do
what ken's talking about because if
you're if you have somebody working for
you
and you're paying them your money out of
your pocket
when would you give them a raise when
they are
adding more value and so if you're
making me a bunch of money or saving me
a bunch of money
more than your income indicates then
that means you are worth more
to us and so um you know we pay you more
and it's
it's that thing that you know are you
causing the revenue to happen are you
causing expenses to go down
either one of which gives me the money
to give and share some of it
with you so you've added actual
value and then a raises a no brainer